[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حلقه جديده من سلسلتها فوات
بعيدن ورقه تقر له تحركاتها بالخطوه اجلس
صافح اتجه الى اليمين التقط صوره كشفها
زوم احدى الكاميرات اثناء حضوره قمه
مجموعه العشرين اظهرت اللقطه المقربه
الرئيسه الامريكي وهو يراجع تلك التعليمات
التي قالت ستجلس في المركز وستلقي ملاحظات
افتتاحيه كما ضمت الورقه ملاحظات لكيفيه
التعامل عند القاء خطابه وفي الجزء العلوي
والسفري من الورقه طلب التعليمات واضحه من
بيض وبخط عريض ان يقوم بقلب الصفحه لرؤيه
بانه لافتتاحيه ومن جديد اثاره الخلق
الواقعه جدلا وقلقا حول الصحه وسلامه بيض
الذي لا يخلو ظهوره العام او اي من
خطاباته من الهفوات والمعلومات الخاطئه او
مجرد النسيان الكامل للموضوع الذي كان
يتحدث عنه
ولم تكت تلاحظ ورقه التعليمات التي حملها
بيض معه في عده محافل ابرزها قمه 2021 مع
بوتن الا ان عيون النسر للمصورين كشفت
فحواها ورغم ان ورقه التعليمات لا تفارقوا
بيضين الا ان حلقه جديده من عفوته لا تبدو
امرا مستحيلا